not even the former rather
commander-in-chief is exempt from jury
duty a large crowd gathered hoping to
catch a glimpse at former President
Barack Obama as he walked through court
in his hometown mr. Obama is the
highest-ranking former public official
to be called to jury duty in Chicago he
was smiling seemed glad to be there
Adriana Diaz is outside the Richard J
Daley Center where the former president
set with other potential jurors
yesterday imagine being in that jury
pool
good morning unique weeks now that the
former president would be reporting here
to court sometime in November but we
just didn't know the date then suddenly
yesterday the typical groan associated
with jury duty turned to Glee when word
spread that mr. Obama would be reporting
for his civic duty the last time you had
jury duty chances are a chopper didn't
capture your commute and your fellow
jurors like Walter Palmer didn't show
off their summons like golden tickets
it's an important duty for all of us so
if he's gonna show up I guess we all
have to show up upstairs even non jurors
showed up cell phones drawn so now Joe
she's a clerk in the building gorgeous
in minutes images from inside his social
media he shook hands and signed books I
think it's really amazing that here in
this situation I'm his equal I can't
believe that I live in a place where
that's true
perhaps the jury room is the ultimate
equalizer just like everybody else
Oprah got wanded down when she was on
the jury for a Chicago murder in 2004 in
2015 former President George W Bush
displayed his civic camaraderie in
Dallas though he wasn't picked for the
jury that same year then candidate
Donald Trump rolled in to jury duty in
style it's a great process it's the only
way to do it you have to do it president
Trump wasn't selected either neither was
President Obama but Cook County's Chief
Judge Tim Evans hopes his willingness to
serve helps rebrand jury duty do you
hope the buzz and excitement
I do hope it lasts and I hope it's
multiplied mr. Obama was able to take
the private judges elevator to get
upstairs but he was not spared the
20-minute instructional video on how to
be a good sir he was also paid seventeen
dollars and 20 cents for showing up what
she says he plans to donate back to the
county jail I think that's pretty cool
you go in the president of unite the
point that the woman made and said on
this day we are all equal situation the
system is fair yeah it does yes and I
know you like going to jury duty yes
I've been twice and I wasn't selected I
thought I'd be good on a jury too but
they said by game I've served once
before
fascinating I think so too I like the
process